en los últimos meses la relación entre
francia y turquía se ha vuelto cada vez
más tensa ahora estará en medio de una
profunda disputa diplomática luego de
que el presidente erdogán sugiriera en
dos ocasiones que el presidente macrón
debía revisar su salud mental francia
respondió retirando a su embajador en
ankara por primera vez en la historia de
ambas naciones
en estos días el individuo a la cabeza
de francia se ha sorprendido está
obsesionado con erdogán de día y de
noche y el rencor de erdogán hacia
macrón está fundamentado en su promesa
por luchar en contra del extremismo
islámico y su defensa a las caricaturas
del profeta mahoma una opinión que ha
molestado a muchos en el mundo árabe
pero en francia es un aspecto importante
de la libertad de expresión no vamos a
hacer nunca respetamos todas las
diferencias en espíritu de paz no
aceptamos el discurso de odio y
defendemos el debate razonable siempre
estaremos del lado
dignidad humana y los valores
universales y no es sólo la libertad de
expresión la que fragmenta las
relaciones ambos países son aliados en
la otan pero ankara y parís discrepan en
temas de política exterior francia le
solicito a turquía detener la
exploración de petróleo y gas en aguas
disputadas con grecia las dos naciones
tienen diferentes soluciones para
abordar el conflicto en siria libia y
nagorno karabaj